she pulls out like a 20 or something
like that out of a pocket rolls that boy
up pops him in the bag leans the chair
back right and just in like hard so it's
2 a.m. the drunk hour when the magic
phrase last call drives the inebriated
into the streets I pick up this couple
it was obviously a date and the girl had
like flowers the guy was completely
drunk we get to the location she says
okay we got to get him out
so you can take me home she said I'm not
she says okay I will take him out to the
curb then I'll get back into the car and
does that before she could close the
door he jumps into the back seat no I'm
not leaving you aah so she gets out
trying to coax him out and I said sir
you really have to leave the car and
then he changed what are you talking
about he gets out and he gets into the
driver side and he starts throwing
punches raining blows on my head
rapid fire are you serious I am
completely serious I'm sitting there
holding up my arms trying to deflect it
and then I get a hold of his wrist so he
can he's giving me the death stare
trying to throw punches he gets out goes
around opens up the driver's side door
yeah to try and get a better shot at me
and I end up just driving off where the
doors open yeah the doors open I Drive
down a couple of blocks and then I start
writing to the app say yeah this guy
made me feel unsafe he'd caught up to
where I was and starts beating on the
driver's side window I tried to drive
away he's trying to get him he's trying
to he's like trying to confront a car
what are you gonna do I Drive past him
yeah drive down a lot longer maybe a
mile or so I finish up driving and then
I noticed he left his phone in the car I
did not go back I kept that thing I took
it to the hub where they have the real
people there yeah went to them I filled
out the form here's this guy's phone
this is this ride you guys can deal with
returning it to him I don't want to see
this guy yeah and I don't know what they
did they said they may be temporarily
banned him but they said as far as
anything further we'll take the
appropriate action so I don't know what
happens it was maybe about 2:30 night 3
o'clock when the bars are all out and
I'm trying to find this guy and all of a
sudden I hear like a whistle
so he sits in the back he's cool like
he's this British rocker you know we're
talking we're putting on some really
good music and we're just jamming out
and I can kind of like smell that he's
like smokes which is kind of like my
pickup line you know like oh like do you
want to have cigarette
he goes yeah so we decide to have a
singer ghost but he said let me sit in
the front and I said yeah totally
the mood is great and then all of a
sudden I'm starts rubbing on my leg and
I was like whoa and then so like the
thing is like I was into two so I
started rubbing on his leg and and so we
just stopped the car and the thing is is
that you know we start kissing and it
gets hot and heavy he whips out his song
and and yeah and I was playing with his
junk whatever and he's British so you
know that means are uncircumsized but I
know I know
so the thing is his died while the clock
was I walk I'm a chorus I'm gonna try
I'm gonna charge for that [ __ ] we get
hot and heavy and the thing is that he
wanted to [ __ ] me he says like I wanna
[ __ ] you and I was thinking like wow
like I usually I mean after like the
first like 30 minutes usually like it's
an hour the night that easy and we don't
have protection I'm this guy's nuts so I
was like well this is a little bit much
maybe go back to my place and he goes
don't no no we can't go back to your
place and I said I don't think it's
gonna happen we didn't finish from there
or anything I dropped him off and like
when I see him he's still jerking off
like he really wanted him because he was
that drunk he stars five stars of course
he's rush hour so I was like five six
o'clock I get a request in this girl off
the CLA campus and so I pull up and I
see this girl walking towards me and she
looked like she just got out of bed so
she walks it over so she's just tired
she comes with me she's like hi are you
Eddie and I'm like yeah she goes hi she
gets in the front seat which already I'm
like oh my god so she hasn't front
seating she goes we're going to the
corner of Franklin and Whitley in
Hollywood I go all right and she goes
how long I take it I was like well it's
rush hour now so like I don't know 45
minutes to an hour she goes it was me
and Jesus I was like are you okay just
hits fine
we were driving we start talking about
just boyfriends and girlfriends dating
also and she comes on the topic of drugs
and she goes have your donors before and
I go no I have it so when she goes oh
we'll just you know we're gonna pick up
drugs okay I go oh
so we're going to pick up drugs we're
driving along Wiggy we get to Hollywood
Franklin Whitley with the corner the sky
she's texting has not responded yet
we're just sitting there on Whitley just
kind of like so what's what a word what
was next what do we do that finally the
guy responds blue Nissan northwest
corner I'm like all right that sounds
Shady so she gets she goes okay wait
here and I wait there and she goes
Baikal
I waited probably like ten minutes so
she gets back in the car
TV back home driving along and she pulls
out two like dime bags from her bra as
she goes okay do you any like give me
paper and I was like no I was all I had
was like a wrapper and that's like she
goes making plans she pulls out like a
20 or something like that out of her
pocket rolls that boy up pops up in the
bag leans the chair back right and just
in my car and I was like oh my god so I
Drive her I Drive her back drop her off
she leaves the car that was it people
are crazy California is crazy expected
hope for the best expect the worst gird
your loins people
[Music]